all right welcome to the live stream
sorry we're late
we had a wonderful ladies night it went
out a little long but now we're here and
now you can watch me basically get
crushed by all of you so all right we're
gonna start this is um Ashley garland I
was gonna say he's my daughter I'm
standing in for my daughter because she
is sick or recovering sick she'll be
here next week
hello okay I started my first game
hi I'm playing black and it says our
rating is 1500 with a question mark but
watch that just dips throughout this
hour I'm not white right nope I'm
waiting for my opponent maybe they
Raymond nirvan Raymond says hello hello
hello thank you huh okay oh I see I see
I'm dumb I'm forgetting that I'm so okay
okay okay
we'll be fine we'll be fine hi Bobby
older all right I'm here I'm gonna get
that username wrong there we go
all right bye and 15 so um who was I
gonna say I have so many things I could
say I I don't do as good as Jonathan
trance obviously no one can can pull off
a Jonathan surance like Jonathan shrimp
but I know all of our club activities I
know all of our classes and everything
like that so we have a question what
time controls will you be accepting well
my favorite is 10 15 20 minutes oh I
keep forgetting
this camera I'll please I'll play it
flew a few
Thank You Danny right now do you have a
time control well I'm playing a I'm
gonna get the time control I thought it
was three plus five no three plus zero
I'm playing a three-minute zero in two
min I am playing a three minute game
with no increment oh all right
that took me way too long so if Eva was
here that's a little long for me yes I
know I I'm not a rapid and blitz player
I yes I'm sorry I'm casual yet my
challenge to three minutes if that's
okay
yes it's an easy win for you and this is
it's obviously my first time on Twitch
but it's also maybe my third third
fourth fifth wrap it in Blitz game blitz
game so I don't usually run on instinct
I like to think about my move so I'm
trying to get faster too I'm used to
playing so um honest Arabic is one of
our grandmasters and she she does our
advanced lady's class throughout
how long has she been doing like a year
or so and she's teaching all those
ladies how to play rapid in glitch and
she's giving them timers and everything
like that and so they're there we want
them to come and play so I'm just I'm
the first go-around so that they can see
it's not they have they get a better
understanding of what to really expect
so to speak okay and you can help me
play Ashley okay camera shock right now
okay so Bobby Boulder challenge to five
and with the Ghost Face here sure
bad x99 says didn't know that just less
than three was allowed are greater than
three was allowed on the Internet
Joe slime eighty-one hi at st. Louis
chest pop grats on the first episode of
ladies night did I miss the
seven-year-old phenom crushing everyone
well just so you know she's actually 11
she's not a phenom she's just a chess
lover she's definitely she's great she
pleaded she's putting a lot of
scholastic tournaments but the kids have
play scholastic tournaments in st. Louis
someone play to a weekend maybe more so
she's uh she juggles quite a few hobbies
what but she's she's really excited
about playing next week and meeting you
guys so this will definitely be her
first experience doing something like
this just like me so twitch we're on
twitch yeah we're on twitch yes and
we're playing Lea chess
okay so let's see how you're doing
see I'm down well we get definitely have
challenges with being on camera and this
being a first time so right I'm
definitely experienced I'm definitely a
behind-the-scenes I like to behind yes
so oh okay getting close I'll be fine
maybe have you played in any tournaments
me yeah I'm playing on my first online
tournament right now but I haven't
played on Leech s and when I got my job
here at the Chess Club I was advised to
set up an account you know someone was
supposed to be helping me with the same
no no I'm not even I'm talking about
someone else who knows exactly who it is
good game Joe says okay sorry for
wondering that sort of phenom crushing a
beer that's next week gotcha
yeah she could have been here but she
would have had a hacking cough here on
the camera and that probably would have
been really bad in a mic so next week
will be better and not hang your queen
you should play faster and not hang your
queen so solid advice
right so now play the next game and
where's it's a Hoover player playing
Bobby Boulder okay and he's right here
it's been talking to us and so we have a
longer time control now yes yeah so we
had a good class tonight we have quite a
few good classes
all right he is bolder Bobby bolder I
haven't seen llama Lord yet which I'm
sure they're gonna bring up in a second
I'm also waiting for Jonathan Trent's
he'll be here soon
yeah I need a castle soon I shouldn't
have played east six because I blocked
in my bishop and he took advantage of
that I'm sorry what hmm oh my gosh they
can I'm okay you're okay you know we
play that first game and I was looking
at when I look up I just see us right
there but I was so shy one of the ladies
at ladies night said something about
being really intimidated for Ana's class
she went to Ana's class one night and I
can't remember what she said but it was
if I think of it I'll have to say it cuz
it was hilarious made my whole night I
was big for her to come huh yes and I
try to talk to her about the ladies
coming and they were like no we're gonna
go home maybe next week
it's like okay maybe okay so one of our
comments is someone saying their name
only chess that means that they want
they wanna Jonathan trance I know your
vampire chicken Jonathan is Opie play
him
oh so you would pick him your next game
but we're looking at this one right here
mm-hmm
it's Bobby Boulder and he's very cool as
ice with this time not on camera well
the light they also all play the
Grandmaster so what kind of challenge of
mine okay so over here the top chat I
see over here this is I'm looking at the
stream chat so there's two different
chat yeah okay cuz I see dennis is over
here uh-huh so I should be reading that
one that's rude
sorry I'm yelling at me at Boulder out
for his move three minutes or what Oh
the Budapest Thank You emalee dentist
says have you some title panda panda
says I'll play but I'm super trashed
hatchback 176 got them okay play I
barely know the rules
okay so that's nirvan Raymond
chess is my love yeah you're went in ha
ha ha sure why not
maybe it's because I just taught the
class we just taught the class and we
just cleaned up from teaching the class
and we came right in here so lots of
transition time and there was a flood
and we got that taken care of not me I
just saw it yeah we'll have to tell them
about the flood
cuz that threw my whole night off like I
said nights and I heard KN I ate a
vampire chicken I'm holding a baby now's
your chance to beat me Oh hatchback I
will never play vampire Jane
bringing down them
you got scared yeah by the way I just
thought I was coming to see what the
setup looked like to report to my
daughter I didn't know I was gonna be on
actually you should if anything you
should call her a text her and be like
you should go to twitch and it's things
just bub and see me online cuz I
literally did the same thing to my
friends so I think it would be hard to
pull Evie away from Naruto if anyone
knows what Naruto's oh I'm sure there's
gonna be a field that she is an anime
and she was not named for a Pokemon but
yes as you can see on the stream it's
not easy ee I had a I went to school
with a girl whose name's Arielle and
almost everyone she talked to she was
like hey Emily follow your intuition is
that a new queen hey I'm not a rapid and
blitz player I'm a I'm a casual I'd like
to think about what's going on let's see
what panda Panda what's in the L what's
Naruto's awesome see I knew it I like
him as much Oh coach okay see ya
I didn't like I don't like Naruto there
will be those that's okay okay she's 11
so you know LM is Italy that would be
good I'll do it anyway who is it no I'm
not I know who I'm not that I can't go
there yeah yeah I am doing pretty good I
have oh sure I'm not even using my F
rook okay new Devils 101 at st. Louis
chess club hey Emily this is Aditya do
you identify each don't you remember me
from the st. Louis chess club of course
a DITA she said your name wrong and then
I pronounced it correctly and Jo so I'm
81 the st. Louis chess club Brooke oh I
see if it's a bad move why'd you say it
sorry I'll be quiet okay nervous hocus
hokey out
[Music]
okay this dose slime anyone the st.
Louis just for account on Lee chest that
you're playing on has an LM title see
the orange LM next to your name what
does that mean think whoever just
explained that to me
ah Thank You Jo slime oh yes I forgot I
can do that oh I was too late I'm sorry
try to prove just pre move everything I
have never done pre move in my life I
don't know what that will be like all
right I know I should text my daughter
and tell you sure you don't I just okay
now you can go back to the ladies and
say I might do it after doing this and
go Emily in secret background helper to
slime nice one the Ln title is very
sought after and so in right now
Naruto is Ho Kitsch still what's ho
kitch where's hole good I'm not sure
either can you explain us see here we
have it capitalized
Hoka quit an asterisk and then that
looks like it's broke down oh it's
Hokage Hokage okay
it's Naruto reference okay I'm Frankie
Frank 4700 look at this guy pre moving
sorry I'm yelling up there so when
you're pre moving aha what are you doing
let me show you okay so pre move showing
you all your legal moves yes so I pre
move this castle
so do you hover and then really I don't
think it's fixed screen we can't see the
board they want to see the board Danny
not us
that guy in the background gave you
really good advice pre knew everything
yeah that's probably it is it is it
saves time and everything that's good
stuff to know yeah hey did I challenge
the right account Holloway not and say
it Louis Chess Club yeah oh let's
someone says get Eevee to play oh that
means me I'm not even I'm a bee's mom
see Emma oh she's not here see I know
that she would be great they I know they
would be great
plus she probably do that's not true she
might she might do the same as me we
still can't see the board on the screen
to your hopper they can't see the board
Danny all right let's see so you
secretly let's see pawn muncher so you
see gali berate us as you beat us nicely
done new Devils 101 at Saint close st.
Louis Chess Club
hey Emily how are you I'll be playing
the quads tournament tomorrow can you
please register my name yes absolutely
can you get his name sweet I need I need
a notepad I need a piece of paper Square
son there's no current board view we're
working on that so they're taking their
time
Josiah anyone Danny you had one job Oh
thank you okay okay so let's dress up my
name is Aditya
Aditya but it is so kind of like kind of
like that
[Laughter]
I'm having a lot more fun than I thought
good I was very nervous like I said I
like to be in the background yeah well I
heard about twitch on NPR and they were
apologizing about twitch because they
didn't know existed really so that's the
extent of my knowledge of twitch that
people watch live games well there's so
many different it's been Simon everybody
say hi to Ben Simon yeah you got fork
Jonathan shots you got forked I don't
care take it
okay what's your rating it's average
it's so if you go on USCF and you look
me up I'm like 500 but unlike chess comm
I'm like 1,000 there's the board thanks
at st. Louis chess club you're doing
great I'd be nervous too don't sweat it
you're natural
hi Ben Zurich says hi Ben what time
limit do you prefer and also rated or
unrated board go right in you I'm
reading too fast
and I don't I don't care for what's and
rapid because I just I'm not good at
thinking on my feet I have to think for
a while ten minutes I've been playing
four or five minutes
everybody's so nice I was thought that
you'd sit down and see like though
YouTube comments and people just being
mean right so that makes you relaxed so
thank you for being nice out there
I just arrived can we challenge you
girls
yes muncher good job Danny
exquisite corpse on pre move by the way
only pre move captures and force moves
only pre move only pre move captures and
force moves
Josiah 81 at kureta Farokh oh yes just
sent me you a challenge on li chess and
exquisite corpse if you pre move
something and they attack a piece your
piece will hang if you pay me something
yes I didn't know that yes love-hate
chest
oh no you miss Mayton - i miss Mayton -
my helpers aren't being very helpful
yeah okay nirvan raymond yeah you are
501 us CF c i played in a staff y
tournament at the club yeah and i was
the one that got the most rating points
because it was your first rated yes yes
okay so it was like 200 300 and then it
went up a bunch so that was really so
Ben got a lot of hellos hello and panda
panda hello Ben Simon - yep panda Panda
I'll wait for another game it's a casual
tennis are you gonna go cry because of
that move yes thank you Frank 47 yeah it
was pretty Adrienne proned arrow I
challenged you to a game he's got his
name which we've got about 14 games
right and the Q I'm sorry I wasn't
paying attention I was just like there
you've got a lot of challenges it looks
like there's 14 in the queue there so we
will be playing until 9 right so are we
gonna do them eenie meenie miney moe -
fun things
you play right here yes they challenged
me up here so I have 15 challenges and
almost all of them are online and you
got their rating there too right is that
our st. Louis just all accounts rating
I'm down on time you just gonna take it
that's why thought it up can't go there
this isn't good Jonathan do you know how
to checkmate with two bishops I'm
playing Jonathan Trump's oh I know I'm
sorry Ashley
oh I'm getting there's so much going on
I think Evie will be great though
because she said some plays YouTube
roblox and then talks to her friends on
chat she'll be great on here good yes
yeah it's not past a school night you
know well I was afraid that it might be
too late she's alright okay good and I
lost some time okay so how are we gonna
pick next how about you pick Ashley okay
so this is their username this is their
rating this is the time control so this
is rated three minutes less two second
increment Duggar they're right yeah okay
so if I can scroll back through the chat
up here which I don't know if I can I
know that I know the rules was talking
to us early I barely know the rules
yeah I barely know the rules maybe I
just like that name
I'm letting you pick I think they're
bluffing well you see this rating that
says 2300 yeah that's fine okay
classic Bensimon crashing ladies night
what you guys could see his face
I'm Victor one hat hi Emily could you
please play me next oh look how nice
they asked nirvan Raymond and then me my
name is I barely know the rules okay
well he just knocked on you for being
501 or he looked up your rating so he
didn't knock he was being nice and
letting you know your rating why am I
thinking about this sorry no because
it's well for me it's 839 so that's
about the time that I'm unwinding this
is the time I want to play chess but
really I should play chess when I'm
drinking coffee in the morning not at
the end of the day I've learned that
yeah
when I'm waking up my mind is going to
sleep mm-hmm which is also I had I
wonder when most people when Lee chess
is the most active because the
demographics probably younger so it's
probably busy or at night Radley
probably yeah because before kids I
stayed up till like 2:00 and 3:00 and
was doing active things at night that's
not right okay too strong for me Gigi
Emily okay what's GG good game good game
Emily okay did you have our chicken say
that yeah nirvan Raymond play me civvy
yeah they they all want to play yeah hey
play okay the empire chicken you were
crushing me you can be anyone he's being
sweet
Luke hazard challenged sent also hi new
Devils ten eleven that's it let's check
out who will win the Superbowl who's
playing this the Rams that are not in
st. Louis are playing not them yep and
they are playing the page Patriots would
know better than me I was on a run okay
with my running friends and nobody
talked about the Superbowl there's like
15 people and st. Louis nobody's talking
about football I don't think it's
probably because the ransom yeah
everyone she was definitely crushing you
I can't hear you
chest is my love I played chess at night
when I'm drunk but chess is my love do
you play well at night when you're drunk
cuz I just I mean I don't really get
drunk anymore plate I didn't start
playing chess til that was past that you
know staying up late and do it
so I don't know is there is there a huge
segment of people playing drunk chess
and I getting's go to want their ratings
just tanked maybe if they're doing
pretty good
who will win this okay I looped hazard
who will win the Super Bowl bad acts 99
thought Fischer said he busted this
opening looped hazard and she gave it
away like a Georgia State co-ed oh how
about he gave it away like a Georgia
State oh I got forked play um whatever
next rest in peace tonight said
Galahad's easy see I can't even look at
the game because the comments irk I know
but you don't have to you don't have to
do it it's I don't have to read them
yeah you're okay
see it's also hard for me to talk and
think yeah apparently I can't do two
things at once that's alright they
probably don't expect my mouth to move
so much they're watching chess right
yeah yep that's what I was thinking
right there see yeah and I'm not used to
I'm not used to kibitzing on someone
else's game I'm not so I'm gonna take
this block off it oh I can't maybe if I
had the watch off I'd be able to promote
nice to meet you yeah I keep saying
Aditya
add each other I'm sorry I'll get it
right and I'll meet you in person that's
it
right nice to meet you good look at your
tournament tomorrow night it's oh I got
to start moving because I'm really down
on time mm-hm yeah
somebody commented it's difficult to
listen to the streamers while playing
against them this is a whole new breed I
wonder no that wouldn't work oh yeah
I keep thinking I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna keep moving which is probably not
a good idea yeah whatever yes please
tell me or I will take any and all
advice that was bad man let's just run
away again oh let's go down here
I'm just moving stuff yeah there's no
point out right now uh I mean I know
there's gotta be terminology that I
don't know to about about blitz uh-huh
because I climb and there's so much
vocabulary I should just take that's
happening and I'm sure that streamers
are probably all over right and he's not
putting any of his sure why not I don't
want you to have passed Khan that was a
bad trade
I'm really tired I have to go to bed I
lost on time
okay we got to hide all right next oh
look here just scroll up okay
how about it's okay so we played Nirvana
Raymond
Jonathan is Opie okay don't drink and
chest sorry just like that name is that
the guy who was talking about yeah yeah
maybe
let's see Nirvana and she group but
let's see what is your friend new
devil's 101 can you see that you want
that one that is your friend maybe I
shouldn't let you pick but I'm letting
you do it I don't see any Devils okay
hold on
you need a second to collect yourself
between games oh that would be really
nice yeah get a drink we had wine at
ladies night yeah okay you can call me
Addie I thought I saw all right Frankie
how about Frankie Frank 47 all right
someone please tell Evie's mom she can
skip the garbage comments haha okay
thank you I'm learning there is an
optimal alcohol amount for all tasks on
a bell curve agreed okay so they're
playing Frankie Frank let's see if he's
still there he probably didn't realize
haha Karen's Cup that's how you say it
curtain family back here and there's cop
next week guys world class women's
tournament at the club
no wait a pre-move Oh howdy 11s dear
friends yeah this is quite the challenge
I've never every time I play chess game
I don't talk yeah who'd have thought
well I try when I play the pure
beginners I take lots of breaks and just
chat because I feel like it's a lot play
chess right like playing the how do you
like teaching the class by the way love
it you do I love making people feel
relaxed about playing chess I feel like
that's something that I can do and I
always tell people that like I'm a
beginner so like no pressure
okay that's good I feel like that's what
I can bring to appear beginners is
that's good I'm you never stop learning
of course I remember one ladies night I
was teaching these ladies and they were
just so scared to move yeah they were
just thinking about their moves and I
was like be aggressive just take it yeah
compared to kids who are moving moving
moving to pieces but I tell the ladies
that the more mistakes you make the more
I have to correct and the quicker you
learn that sound back yes yes yes no one
doesn't sound bad and you know when you
look over you're trying to look through
the room and see how everybody's playing
and you don't see movement on the board
your eyes move on to the next board so
you can miss that they don't understand
unless they're yes okay Wow let's see
Howard I feel so dumb for not realizing
that and I still gotta move I am so not
used to this time control I just want to
take all the time in the world to think
about everything good for you rude yeah
that's I expected nothing less
you sure you don't want to play one I
can no you do not have to you yeah
there's a lot there's a big learning
taking right here for all that's going
on oh yeah but that's permitted
obviously because it helps Jo slime
talks a lot while playing online chests
usually a lot of f-bombs you know that
sort of thing we're not allowed to do
that here my boss will watch this later
I'm Victor says you guys are the best
see you're getting some oh that's sweet
too chicken to play rated bok-bok-bok
hatch I said I would play right in
because it's not really my account I
challenge two plus one should I change
yeah I think we're gonna play we're not
gonna play two plus one and yeah you got
talking going on got chatter here
cameras quite the experience but hopeful
mm-hmm and it might not be night
wherever they're at right I'm assuming
it's night but it might not be night it
might not be the tundra of st. Louis
right it could be probably a tropical
beach we're gonna just my queen there
you just taken up my pen game will be
interesting
all right let's try something ah you
made it
so I have no reading because I haven't
played a real tournament I keep wanting
to do the ones here please playing one
of our tournaments because you can win
money and Jonathan insurance has already
talked about that I'm sure and you get
to play chess to your heart's desire so
you think what time is it
I got more time right oh I got minutes
all right thank you
come on Evie let's play John cor disco
shark glasses by the way thank you is
any glasses sharp and cheap you should
still text your daughter and tell her to
watch online oh do you want to use one
of my phones no I'd have to call we have
a landline she doesn't have a phone
she's 11 abused I knew that I'm sorry
there are a lot of 11 year olds with
phone so that's probably why I'm you
watch them go inward you know as soon as
that happened so yeah I guess I guess
that's the world nowadays okay Joe so
I'm yeah we're on a nice warm tropical
beach huddled around our lap stops
watching chess
that's a lose I just got sound amazing
and I'm incredibly jealous okay panda
said I'm fast i won thank you okay so
Adi who you playing a ruby sea turtle I
like that name oops okay I don't remove
that okay I don't even know what I
understand I just totally screwed up
everything
no you don't have to yeah I feel like
I'm pressuring you so you don't don't
feel pressure everybody's nice here so I
don't know I don't have a rating and
tomorrow gonna be lit and my Kumar
tomorrow gonna be lit and Mike both
really blundered oh yeah
and yeah
have a helper
yeah tomorrow February 1st
this is you will realize if you do play
difficult that's to talk and play oh I
bet because I can't really even play
beginner chess with my classes if I
start talking mm-hmm because I teach
kindergarteners teenagers mix age my
homeschoolers rude let's take it and I
don't think I can talk to any of them
and play the ladies hello from come on
Evie I will challenge you I knew they
would free Bishop oh I I wish I could
talk and play at the same time you'll
get better huh just give me a regular
gig your twitch feed over there did
better at chess maybe no I understand
that why I like you you're gonna want to
watch me play before you play I'm really
glad I'm really glad I thought she
wouldn't really enjoy it I need to get
my night out start doing stuff with it
not utilizing all the pieces I still
don't remember what that woman said I'm
so frustrated that it made my whole
night it was like the funniest thing
basically she was just saying how she
went to Anna's class for the first time
and was just like scared straight
cuz she didn't know what was going on
and she was really nervous and they
weren't seem to really enjoy my class
which is good sure you kind of forget
about that until you're put in a new
situation and mm-hmm maybe you look
exactly like my cousin Jennifer Wow
well my name's Ashley and Jennifer
Edie's my daughter she should be here
she'll be here next week so she'll look
exactly like me but 11 years old
Jennifer was the name before Ashley
so I was born in 78 and Jennifer's were
like 77 and before that was the pup so
when you say Jennifer like that's
totally right probably the same age as
me can you say hello to my dad he's
called Tessa po Li Kapoor how do we send
it say hello hello dad no can't do that
no hello dad my dad is not watching this
my dad is asleep no you had a passed
pawn
okay time you're doing good on time
oh yeah I guess I'm down on time oh yeah
you can see my game duh
I'm thinking well I can't see it's
really funny because I love watching my
comer and Dennis and Jonathan play
because I'm sure that they have some
trouble talking and playing but it
doesn't look like it yeah now you know
what they're going through so roll so
Ferrari good luck as a fellow st. Louis
see and I'm looking forward to hopefully
getting down to the Chess Club soon
what's stopping you maybe the eight
degrees an icy road true where is he
where are you because that could also be
the problem
yeah not being in a radius yeah traffic
is not bad in st. Louis hello daughter
that's funny I mean that's a free pawn
why shouldn't I take it yeah take it I'm
gonna see it I want to move my knight
here that night why do I keep doing this
ever even in my classes I will call rook
a knight and a knight of rook I'm
Chester yeah so so why wouldn't you move
your rook in there because it's
protected I'm just nervous because I ha
so if I had pre moved in the end of that
well he heard me talking to right Arthur
a delay I think there is a small delay
now you're attacking though I think
there is a small delay don't turn over
Cherokee side
what else yeah
I could've just taken them Bishop to
he'll probably move this bishop now I
said that though I guess we'll find out
delay is only like five seconds thank
you okay good
okay rolls yeah very come in West County
I'm in the Central West End quite a bit
but have actually never stopped in goal
for February to finally come on in you
should it's a beautiful place it's very
very nice comfortable in here where is
he
West Cammy oh yes not for one tip don't
both talk at the same time
oh yeah cuz it'll mess them up okay the
bishop was free honestly I thought it
was checkmate
because they could have clean rot no no
it's not checking those regular members
are rubbing off on me now
viewers are dominating well that's okay
oh I knew they would I knew they would
panda panda says I'd love to go to st.
Louis just for the Chess Club
there's so much that's fun here in st.
Louis and chess club is definitely a
great part of it if you kind of st.
Louis you'll find plenty to do City
Museum to God I hope soon music I'm
supposed to go to the same museum with a
friend of mine the other day I was there
last week and I asked is there a chess
set there should be a chess set
somewhere we should paint the pieces
that would be a really good idea and
they said you know that requires
concentration so I thought well if it
was somehow on a wall maybe uh-huh then
again yeah that works
magnetic metal maybe some kind of maybe
yeah I might have better faith
no mate bishop f8 was available to avoid
mate too late it's probably not helpful
for me to read it's always too late
that's okay yeah well Jonathan does a
really good job of reading the humo
sleep allow questions about the club
itself like okay you know or hold on I
got to think about this
lots of indie movie theaters in st.
Louis like the Tivoli no kidding
why am i moving my night there because I
can't rest Club opened a year after I
moved out oh sorry exquisite corpse I'm
gonna make it I think
this is much better than I thought tech
yeah it's nine o'clock is it yeah my
watch is slow I got five minutes
oh it says nine o'clock yeah do you want
one more game or do you want to you know
I should yeah you should get out of here
actually I could probably take one of
the guys if you want to get out of here
okay yeah so next week I'll come back
with Evy and maybe I'll play something
if she's feeling nervous
well so what are we on with her what
I'll do is I'll sit where you're sitting
Evy will sit where I'm sitting and if
you want we have the other chairs so you
can know that if you want to do that
yeah I can I can play and let her watch
and absorb what's happening yes and then
she can take over the reins because I'm
doing badly and she'll want to well if
you don't have to but I will play if you
yeah what is matter Oh next next next
week okay Dennis are you gonna take her
spot I love it I don't know if he can
take no one can take your spot okay I
will miss you and I will see everybody
say goodbye you have a wonderful night
and you will see her more if you come to
ladies night on Thursday this Thursday
nights at 6:30 what am i stood on my
words
[Music]
thanks bye thank you for coming to the
rescue dentists need to wash your eyes
I'm sorry I just hurt you so much bye
Ashley it doesn't matter I'm sorry that
I hurt you so deeply Danny on Mike's eye
I guess I'm climbing okay all right
careful careful okay yeah zopi was lucky
mr. vampire chicken it's so lucky are
you what you know is Dennis so tall your
evolution favored me that's fine
Danny's peaked you softly I'm having
such a good day
do you have an invisible friend called
Danny because excuse me I do okay all
right fair enough don't your knight is
hanging the knight on c3
he's probably shouting the same thing at
you this guy no no Danny's good enough
to give you a suggestion I just gonna
tell you hey he's attacking that guy I
get that but he's not gonna take it
I can't yeah that's right at least you
know you will you got lucky vampire
chicken you got lucky
oh it was an accident what's their
rating it's their prove they're
perplexed they wanna hear nothing maybe
they'll only can you do my Dennis the
root is the root that's that's the chain
see she didn't even know Jonathan she
didn't even know it where am I looking
this one okay no no I'm not okay
do you want to talk about it no but I do
want to talk about vampire chickens
comment to the chat yeah whenever I walk
in the club Jonathan rightly thinks it's
hilarious to chant my name he does the
same thing - Emily Trask is that all you
get a little singsong mine is just Dan
it's the route Dan that's the route I
like it it's like a it's like a War
Chant there's another there was the song
- yeah because its tactics time with
Dennis yeah no yeah he had like a little
Limerick right Jonathan yeah if he can
solve it then neither can you right
something like that I've never heard of
it I'm not doing so good I try I try a
new devil try thank you for the support
so yeah just dig it okay I guess I'll
listen to you
you do a wonderful job of commenting I
do I try I try Thanks
held the message for reasoned okay Evie
is a girl's name well we don't need to
we don't need to indulge well they're
gonna figure it out anyway
people say well I mean I'm just saying
like anyway I'm tired you're doing great
the chat rooms doing great everyone's
doing great is everyone doing great yeah
I'm all about the positive thinking
Emily I've noticed I've noticed some
people at the club being a little
negative from time to time telling other
players hear you I can't repeat it but
you stink basically is what they're
saying or you're bad at chess and I'm
just like you know this is not the
environment for that that kind of
attitude chess is a fun environment for
happiness and positivity that's right
that's right
I shouldn't even Castle should I you we
should resign at this point and all
honesty but we're just having fun
positive it's like never resigned
because you should yeah I guess I can't
Castle yeah I can't do anything okay oh
okay
such great helpful advice an hour later
Dennis telling it like it is
yeah sure I just still resign Dennis we
can just give him one more piece why not
okay Oh work me one we got some
counterplay piece activity rugby one
let's go the worst all right
I don't I don't know what that means
literally I literally just taught double
attack in my class yeah no there's a
voice in my say in my head saying that
Queeny for might be a move oh my god he
found it
okay good game this is where we say good
game mister don't don't drink in chess
very funny you want me to give up boom
fight fight on you're a warrior fight
yeah King g1 or f3 mmm you got this
never will actually everyone here is the
one that's like you never give up yeah
yeah vampire chicken I'm gonna give up I
just got worked I shouldn't I shouldn't
I I have no keys three you got plenty of
space really quick he's got a queen a
night another night
those guys are asleep in another those
are lazy soldiers your soldiers are
working hard those are lazy soldiers in
the corner Dennis pick my next
challenger and then not that guy I'll do
two more games Eddy Eddy go that guy oh
yeah we gotta design the game first you
just clicked it take it again what is a
good game good game don't drink and
chest thank you yeah yeah I watch a lot
of anime formal politeness in a quick
off-topic question what is your favorite
anime you gonna attack on Titan oh yeah
okay you just think about it a little
bit modern stuff
oh yeah cuz your other one is Cowboy
Bebop Akira
and now go back to the challenges and
accept the challenge for many it's and
it's casual addy you gotta play us rated
stuff if you want to play us Oh has to
be written yeah I'll play this guy
mister a rod code because I think we
played Victor Gaucho already before ok
designed in the drawn position well said
- super - okay so I need don't pick
anyone over a thousand cowards cowards
but wise that's just support cowards
it's a coward a really smart do you want
to know I guess we'll leave that for
what for your invisible friend I don't
know develop your stuff yeah great we
don't stop freaking okay
sorry you're great you're doing great
sure
we're gonna play when I leave I know I
probably gonna end the stream and have
to shut the club down oh yeah I guess
that's the thing I know yeah okay
understood understood just live I did
not yeah I did not want to talk I steal
hmm
that's a four oh wow you're practicing
your coordinates as you play good job
take that point we don't need ya take
that guy take the rock and take the pole
or you don't even need just take the
pond you need to take okay you sure you
don't want to stay bent Simon I don't
know what that means
oh you're all out of everything Wow Ben
Simon is strangely oh yeah you enjoy
that have a good night okay well bye Ben
Simon Dennis is leaving the building
stream Dennis I guess he's kind of a
lady whoa whoa I'm leaving right now
what is it going on here it's just
friendly better not there's anything not
that there's anything wrong with being a
lady yeah there is nothing wrong with
being a lady I'm in my chest
whoa what for the readings yes because
that is a hanging night I'm sorry I'm
just nervous
you're that's amazing the way it's yeah
you think out loud it's such a unique
thing I can't think out loud you and
you're doing great you're doing really
good just because the hanging bishop
bored because how women can't play chess
Dennis would make a very tall lady this
is true how are you Dennis get Ben out
of there Dennis can stay he's gone
vampire chicken he's gone I'm like ten
feet tall very good you play basketball
for a 10-footer that's right
yeah whatever the little voice from your
head is saying that's the wrong I can
hear it you're thinking so hard I can
hear I try really hard I try really hard
I think queen g4 is what we want in many
lines here we want to get our queen
there and say checkmate and that maybe
not yeah Bishop f6 don't don't let me
I'm really bad at this
alright there's probably some more
sophistical you realize you're reading
is much better than mine this guy queen
g4 hey Denis sing a song you should sing
a song you did it it's great and simple
mate yeah she is a master
she's the Trask master okay okay one
more one more game one more this is so
tall yeah that's true I would love to
play this guy but I can't
de de fer a great comment I need to try
read this onomatopoeia that vampire
chicken is just please no help as even I
don't know what that means
new devils who are you new Devils what's
your a d11 well dude you're doing it
casual you got a well he might have
redone it yeah
another time for him yeah some yeah we
need the rated games man we needed a not
that guy I know
I know I know it hurts just do a five-o
standard fake to Gaucho's okay we played
him a lot random chess dude that's 300
we're gonna die hold on
let's try the int to increment it's
either one of these two whichever one
you want it doesn't matter
play me I'm 2,000 you're scary stay away
from me a new friend created challenge
given oh yeah okay we got two new Frank
who we got you literally use that term
in my class today I was like if you're a
noob of chess and you don't know what to
do six okay all right no you you don't
you think the French is a little
scaredy-cat move that's fine um that's
good well yeah I like it I like it
classically plastic all right let's just
do what I know mm-hmm okay okay no no I
just I just scare me when you say things
like that he's gonna play d4 oh no no
you didn't but you have a piece just
give him but there's a there's some way
hold on think hard there might be a
little voice in your head that has
something for you but here maybe also
just refuses to help in this position
there you go sure okay all right
what's wrong with just developing your
stuff just materials equal your fine
yeah I got a play I do a bunch of
puzzles but I gotta play more alive Jess
you're doing great thank you to
thousands are scary until you realized
that I can beat to thousands that's
right I'm not really scared have you
beat Danny before never I'll never be
Danny and Jonathan Danny Machuca and
Jonathan Shantz are unbeatable
they're the strongest chess players I
kind of wish because live stream one of
their games I know I have inflated Caleb
Dendy oh I'm sorry
he's way stronger than those guys well
maybe those guys look like chill just
compared to Caleb Denby I didn't say it
I didn't say it didn't you Christ John I
have no idea I don't even know what it
came to the Indians
everybody beats Dennis no don't leak
Jackson yeah
beats me all the time Jonathan Sean I'm
sure you haven't beaten me I'm sure you
have beaten me that's why you crushed me
in bughouse and then you make fun of me
remember that time oh yeah we should
talk about my my my book house skills
you are awesome in bughouse never if you
come to the club and challenge us in
bughouse we will send you home crying
you will go home in tears bughouse crazy
people in here they're trying to block
this one we should allow we should uh we
should yes good job production yes
more like a tactical lizard some people
yet some people identify with being a
tactical wizard I see what you're saying
what's going on
what it we're gonna let's pause for five
minutes and analyze the position okay or
you could have just played d5 I was
still I still can't are you fine that's
dad do you ever watch Star Trek no it's
kind of no it looks like a face it's
just very futuristic I wish I could
cover the camera zoom in on this mouse
it's okay why are chess players always
thinking
yes I'm one on the lizard person yep
[Music]
hmm are you a tactical wizard or are you
a tactical wizard I already said I'm a
lizard what is the difference
okay do you do you need time to think
about it does the wizard actually that
with the wizards tactics work in the
lizards tactics okay I guess more like
blunders than actual actually
functioning tactics yeah that makes more
sense
what a wonderful game
how are you going to recapture that pond
not that guy it's my mind with your mind
good answer
awesome play by Black here I agree
Carlson why can go home go home crying
but good game will still say good game
and thank you for watching this dream
and would you like a box of Kleenex okay
yeah yeah twenty hundred you know so we
have an employee here in Nick risco who
have you watched this dream you may know
who is 2400 got his rating up to like
twenty three or twenty four hundred on
on leeches Oh seriously yeah but I would
but what I learned is that I play it
like 2400 leech s strength
I must cuz if Nick got his rating that
high and if I just crush him every time
we play blitz then I must be that strong
right see
just say yes Dennis you're right yes
Dennis you're right I agree okay I will
always remember this pin him to the
nothing Thank You Dennis your wisdom is
tremendous
yeah don't but be careful because I'm
young baby hold on there don't make any
no sudden movements what is your USDF
which one us both of us emily is
probably it's still provisional / very
very provisional it's like I that didn't
I was that the move that your little
thank you God is talking to me who is
this man's I don't know who is anybody
that could not have been a move it
wasn't I'm just not thinking yeah well I
mean okay you're doing great
good job
hmm yeah my name is Dennis if you're
really asking I work at the club I teach
lessons here I'm lucky enough to work
here with lovely mistress and others
Bishop III just
I am some basketball player have you
ever played basketball things like have
you ever run or hurt her okay you know
what I mean each student even physical
activity yeah I've done that once or
twice this fee day right yeah yeah
oh yeah do you guys like Dennis's new
haircut show the camera show the camera
you can see Yasser is crying somewhere
for the Misbah 93 because I agree yeah I
agree he might be down the street crying
um but definitely tears are being shed
three moves to go I know I know
yeah dad I'm sure everyone is hurting
right now I know I am you're doing
fantastic oh good
first of all I don't know what cheese
comment Chea type cheese dog I thought
it said she thought corn you should do
your hair like comer for the next dream
yeah I can do a mean comer impression oh
my god I'll bring the gel if you were
playing in the Friday action wash yeah I
can you thought Mike was sitting what is
it I always just say Micah move yeah
to watch learn from ah anything done by
Jonathon Schwantz to answer the question
what's a good ultra beginner chess
series to watch / learn from opening is
explained in advanced edition no edition
when did this become a thing it's just a
sad attempt at a joke
lots of good ultra beginner stuff put
out from the club we have a lot of
scholastic shorts on our YouTube channel
yeah a lot of good stuff on there um you
know I also just use the drop-down on
the Li chess taskbar under learn there
are many good little clicky buttons or
links or whatever that was
yeah that will take you to pages that
will help you get exposed to everything
you need to know about that crank mates
and and the coordinates where is d3 it's
a mystery
over here and why is there a pawn still
on that square I just can't
aah whoa my goodness how was ran' I
should have done it just to see that I'm
sorry well they know the lack take it no
no don't don't listen to me don't listen
to me
luckily they can't see what I was
pointing you I will I will stop
listening to you don't go there for her
on a party in that particular position
standards yeah don't listen to me this
day see I am so beginner break down with
Dennis the root well yeah you have to
come to the club we do uh there's a lot
there are plenty of classes on for the
beginner to it for the pure beginner all
the way to you know stronger class
players
but yeah Monday night we do begin a
breakdown and then Wednesday night
that's a good one with Caleb
Denby woman okay taking stuff oh this
night his night was trapped don't um for
the briefest of moments a whoa the pawn
the puns you have more and they go
forward okay all right yes yes Dennis
yes
Oh Monty oh my yeah let's go conquer
forward you'll never catch us yeah that
guy the guy without one in front of me a
very you know I like to use coordinates
I I'm not strong enough to use
coordinates forward he's too slow in
that laughs eh you're too slow Caine
you'll never catch me there's that root
of me to do that no it's rid of him to
trick
I'm thinking about it too much yeah eh
you okay you know yeah you do you yeah
you do you thank you well axiom infinity
we are glad that you join us that you're
joining us yeah this dream is a new
thing for us on and so far we're having
a lot of fun and getting a lot of
positive feedback so thank you all Tim
good job thank ya good game dude Frank
new print I love it shout out to that
name alright and now I gotta do this
next week yeah thank you to all for
joining us I don't know yeah this we're
going to wrap it up so yeah there should
be a stream schedule somewhere on your
screen there yep there it is Tuesday at
12:00 today is definitely Thursday yes
so tomorrow the day you've all been
waiting for the one